all right so what do you guys want to
start with because there's so much we
could talk about i mean i usually do
these for about 90 minutes
um and i like to leave some time for for
call-in but
every once in a while like i get like a
dm from somebody or there's some really
good conversa actually irishman let's
start with you because you dm me the
other week and you said something along
the lines of dude like this you
actually talk about works
um
what what was your big aha moment like
what was your eye opener with with stuff
that you didn't previously think that
worked as far as at you know like
advanced dating techniques that you
discovered through experience does work
holding frame i it hit me like a train
the last few months
um and i think i told jason when i was
you know as i said i'm 47 and i'm in
some bar and i'm i'm making up with a 26
year old girl and first talk going
through my head was screw cooper he's
right again damn
you know
it sounds pretty funny yeah but the the
thing that i learned most is it's better
to hold frame and lose the girl than
lose frame and live your life on your
knees or live the relationship on your
knees and i went through a situation the
last couple of weeks where a girl flaked
on me for dinner
yeah yeah tell that story yeah so i i
cut her off and you know i i spoke to a
couple of you guys in the community and
you were like well don't be like
butthurt
ghost her just say cool no problem
so 24 hours later i said cool no problem
and then i just dropped it after that it
went on about my life doing my stuff
because i learned i if she's not coming
into my frame i'm not going into her
frame i'm not going to chase her blue
pilbara me in the past would have went
after her would have texted her and said
hey you want to come out wednesday
instead some nonsense like that
so i just went on about my life friday i
get this text
and i just message her back and i say
let's talk so we talk
and you know
she says she's really into me and all
that and i said look i just want you to
know i have standards i said i do not
buckle to those standards you flaked on
dinner if you want to go back out with
me you're going to take me out to my
favorite restaurant which was last night
i said you're going to pay for it you're
going to buy me drinks and you're going
to apologize
and i was like i zfg mode i'm like i
don't care you know i said all those
things i never thought i'd say in the in
the past to a girl you're going to
apologize to me you're going to take me
to dinner so you know all that stuff
happened we went out last night we had a
great time and and this is you know one
thing i want to emphasize is holding
frame is not bossing on chicks or
winning or getting one over on them it's
having self respect and i said to moff
earlier if you were if you're a young
guy listening to this this podcast and
you have never walked off the lot from a
used car dealer you won't be able to
whole frame you have to be able to walk
away from something that you like and
like it a lot
if you can't do that frame's gone
yeah
um
jason you've had some experiences around
frame lately too do you want to do you
want to talk about that a little bit and
the importance of it and yeah
you know it's interesting i was you know
the last kind of long-term relationship
i was in which i ended up five six
months ago um
things were great for the first five or
six months and then
you know for whatever reason
you know things just kind of went
sideways like all of a sudden and um
one of the things i think the folks at
home need to kind of recognize is that
all these guys are are relatively high
value guys right i'll make pretty decent
money i i don't know a lot of these guys
like in person but we've talked enough
that this is a really good high quality
group of people and so
you know you really want
a woman in your life that it is going to
match the lifestyle that you've got
otherwise it turns to a complete mess
and uh you know i was dating a girl for
a while
and it's that death by a thousand cuts
right i think you say like a million
concessions
where at first you're like oh it's not a
big deal because i've got 900 other
things going on something happens
reschedule whatever but then things
really went from
from not so great to bad i was like wait
a second is this
especially for me since i was married so
long so you know i went back to the
community and said hey guys is any of
this normal and all you guys are like uh
this is there's something else going on
here dude
you can't be in a relationship like this
and so uh that was kind of the you know
the big example of that is
is uh hey you and i are not gonna work
out in this
you know in this kind of lifestyle so
i think you just stand your ground and
you you know it's not one of these uh
ultimatums and if you do this it's gonna
happen it's hey look i just don't hate
people that do x y and z
it was literally that simple hey i just
don't date people that do they do they
say if you want to do things that's your
lifestyle is great but that's just not
for me yeah it's setting some boundaries
and having some dignity yeah
yeah that's exactly what it is it's and
and truth be told it's you know a lot of
things that we talked about the very
beginning of a relationship i'm a pretty
public person at least here in the texas
market so one of the conversations we
had we first started dating i said look
you're going to be judged way more harsh
than i ever will because i'm kind of i
got like a little bad boy flavor to me
which everybody's gotten used to because
i've been doing this for a couple years
now but the gals that i bring in my life
said look you know you're going to be
judgmentally harsher some things you
probably can and can't do
um
you know doing
shots
doing shots at the networking event with
all your your peers is probably not
something
that's conducive to a long-term
relationship right so it's stuff like
that where it was like hey i could see
the writing on the wall there this is
not this is not going to work so you
just
just say hey i'm not going to do this
and
of course as you guys know lo and behold
she starts texting me again and all that
and as of you know
i had another conversation with her
weeks ago i was like i don't think this
is really gonna work out so
in any case following one of those rules
um
but yeah that's that was my experience
it literally is
if you go through rollo's book one of
the if you if there's anything that you
can do the one thing you do is that
frame the issue of frame hey this is
my life this is how it's gonna work
happy to have you come along but here's
the here's the box here's the confines
in which this is going to be successful
in it and if it goes outside of that
outside of that frame again you know as
guys you've got to have reasonable frame
can't be invisible right but you know
if you can't really stay within these
rules i mean
probably gotta find somebody else
yeah there's nothing wrong with that i
mean it's just a matter of fit and why
wouldn't you want to establish that
early on especially if you're the kind
of guy that's looking for
a longer-term relationship with a woman
to kind of enter your enter your life
and compliment it and you know for some
guys that might just mean dating it
might be an ltr it might mean having
kids with them right i mean why would
you want to do it with somebody that's
going to complicate your life and it's
why i put that emphasis on the idea that
frame is important and and it's much
easier to set
uh that part of the relationship early
on than it is to try to fix something
a year three years down the road that's
already been broken and already has a
track record of being broken that you
need to you know like reassemble and try
to turn into something useful it's
it's next to impossible if anything you
know i would say
you